All right guys, so this is an example for a short position.
So as you can see, we got the A leg, right?
So let me mark this out very easily.
There you go.
We got the A leg, we got the B leg,
and then we got the C leg.
Perfect.
So now let me mark these out.
So we got the A leg right around here,
which is from here, okay?
And then we got the B leg, okay?
Which is the B leg, this downward move.
So we wanna mark out the very low of the B leg,
which is this, okay?
And we wanna mark out the high of the A leg,
which is this, perfect.
Now the C leg, which is this,
it takes out the high of the A leg, okay?
So the high of the A leg is here,
A leg high, right?
Let me do this, it looks better, there you go.
So the C leg takes out the high of the A leg
while leaving some structure here, right?
So before price took out this high,
it created some structure, okay?
Then when price took out the high,
it made a market structure shift.
So it broke this structure, right?
Then price left the imbalance and auto block.
So this is an auto block, right?
We would enter straight from the auto block,
put our stop-loss right above there
and target the low, which is here.
So that's 5.62, guys.